oh man all right what the hell
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm like app opens I just started when
you open the game all the cops are after
mark now I know
all right success why do we want this I
don't know go places now military base
this was all for they're gonna shoot
missiles at us again
sure yeah I'm not gonna yeah are you
turning your channel into a makeup
channel yes makeup with Wayne yeah this
thing is not stable and we seem to be
smoking not doing well okay this thing
is not handling right now oh god you did
it you guys
again work doesn't get a jam I got my
helicopter
[Music]
what are you in I'm in a helicopter you
and I go to the big helicopters I'm in
the hell
[Laughter]
[Music]